mic Bresnahan he's the Laker analyst for
a spectrum sports net he worked with the
LA Times covering the Lakers for 12
years and he joins us on the program
what was the atmosphere like last night
Mike pretty crazy you know is mostly
clipper fans which you would expect from
a designated clipper hole game at
Staples Center but lots of Laker fans to
some chance for LeBron
the MVP chance also some let's go Lakers
here and there throughout Staples Center
fun game definite playoff type
environment already out here in Los
Angeles how would you describe the
playing styles for both of these teams
Clippers were very physical last night
they try to be very physical with LeBron
very physical ad really tried just about
everything they even had Patrick
Beverley they're a 6-foot point guard
trying to guard LeBron early in the
first quarter didn't really work too
well so they went away from it I think
the Clippers doggedness really got to
the Lakers and the Lakers are still
trying to figure things out you know
they got nine new players
lonna LeBron and AD of course but I
think they miss Kyle Cruz was punch off
the bench because they really got beat
up badly by the Clippers bench what is
the time frame for Paul George you know
that's a really good question what are
the Clippers the best guarded secrets
right now they already said he'd missed
the first ten games of the season so
you're guessing probably another month
or so as he recovers from that shoulder
injury did not look like they needed him
very much at all last night that is a
very strong team with or without Paul
George scary news for clipper haters
knew I would start quite a few here in
LA and they look like a very very good
polish team they've been together for a
long time they did pretty well in the
playoffs last season without Paul George
and Kawhi Leonard then you add those two
that seems tough very very dangerous
team for sure what's your biggest
concern with the Lakers this year
bench step you know I heard a couple the
Lakers kind of talking off to the side
in the locker room last night after the
game and they were looking at the stat
sheet and they said wow the Clippers had
60 points from their bench and the
Lakers had only 19 so you know that that
might that will improve once Kyle Kuzma
comes back from a stress reaction in his
left foot probably another week maybe
two nothing official from the Lakers yet
on a return timetable but the Lakers
really need some bench production rajon
rondo also sat out last night's game
he's probably going to come off the
bench to start the season but they
really need some some depth
Clippers with montrezl harrell Lou
Williams really really to the best
impact bench players in the league
really
the Clippers really shown out there at
their death last night the regular
season is more important to the Clippers
so the Lakers I think the Clippers which
is which is funny to say because the
Clippers announced a couple weeks ago
that Paul George is gonna be missing
some time and the Clippers are kind of
younger the Lakers are much more of a
veteran team you know you got LeBron
turning 35 in a couple months and
definitely some older veterans on the
Lakers Danny green by the way 28 points
last night in his Laker debut this is
this is a funny stat man it's the most
points ever for any Laker in his first
game with that franchise he got really
hot behind the arc but but it's
definitely a veteran Laden team for the
Lakers complete 180 from last season
when they had young guys like Lonzo ball
Brandon Ingram and Josh Hart now they
have all these veterans I'm not sure
that the regular season is as important
to the Lakers as a Clippers though
talking to Mike Bresnahan the Laker
analyst for Spectrum Sports Net and he
was the beat guy for the Lakers for the
LA times for 12 years who else do you
like out west it feels like it's
top-heavy with Lakers clippers but then
I hear people say well Denver might end
up with the best record but who else do
you kind of throw in the mix here yeah I
think they're on point was saying that
the Nuggets have the best record they're
just a real young team I don't think
they know any better
it's not it's not a knock on the nuggets
it's just they're gonna start sprinting
right away they're going to be the team
trying to get to 55 56 wins secure home
court throughout that the west playoff
chase I don't think they win it though
there's just not enough experience you
know championship experience on that
roster you talk a lot of interesting
moves by the Jazz during the offseason
you know we pick up Mike Conley they
picked up Bogdanovich that's the team
that along with Rudy Gobert down to
Mitchell they're gonna make some noise
in the playoffs as well and like know
how to assess Houston all right what is
that back point you've got Russell
Westbrook you've got James Harden that
team in my mind could be anywhere if he
first the eighth in the West quake
appellate very good center but I just
don't know what's that backcourt going
to look like I mean hard still getting
his points in the preseason games but
Westbrook was a little bit up and down I
think it one game we're at eight or nine
turnovers and that could be a little bit
troubling for the Rockets they'll be so
entertaining so fun to watch under
D'Antoni though that's for sure who do
you think LeBron will get traded during
the regular season
I see what you're saying there there's
not a lot of youth on the Lakers besides
Powell Kuzma and he's such a inexpensive
equitable contract for the Lakers
because he was drafted 27th overall he's
only in his third year of his rookie
deal not a lot of money going out so you
can't have a lot of money coming in as
per NBA collective bargaining agreement
rules so I think this is kind of what
they are there's just not a lot of space
on the roster maybe they make a play to
get Andre Iguodala might cost them a
round er but they've already treated a
bunch of their first rounders together
yet to me Davis yeah so this might be
who they are for the rest of this season
is it enough to wait at all that's the
huge question here in LA and a few more
people are asking it
after seeing last night's for although
it's not really panic time for any team
you know after one game half the NBA
teams will be winless and half them will
be undefeated so it's you can't get too
crazy right now
what is hello Mike and there's gonna be
it feels like this is almost like the
NFL where every game we have a
referendum on a team or a player you're
gonna be doing that for 82 games this
year it feels like with the Lakers and
the Clippers so good luck doing that oh
I I can't wait to read the local
colonists opinions from last night bill
plashy I'm sure he wasn't hammering away
drafted I came you know boom for the
Lakers and a championship on the way
from the Clippers I love Bill and I love
reading everyone's stories out here but
the Lakers just draw so much fire after
a loss no matter what time of year it is
and so much compliments and coddling
after a win even if it was just a season
over obviously that did not happen for
them last night they'll be back at
practice and I figured and I'm curious
but both of these teams aren't
three-point shooting teams and it wasn't
that the new norm or am I missing out on
what their strategy is going to be you
know Green is a good three-point shooter
look the bran can be capable three-point
shooter
cooze Mo's but like but you look at some
of these other teams where
a little bit more three-point shooting
happy than the Lakers and Clippers are
they trying to change the new like is
this the new style is the old style in
the NBA that's a great question and I'll
answer on the Lakers because I think
they really tried to address this right
the last two the last four seasons
they've been 29 29 22nd and 30th in
three-point shooting and I think they
tried to address that during the
offseason so they pick up Danny Green
they pick up a Quinn cook who had his
moments as a backup point guard for the
Warriors they try to add the Marcus
cousins who can hit some hit some threes
here and there obviously he's out for a
long time with a torn ACL that he had a
pickup game a month ago so they tried to
add a couple guys who can maybe get them
up from that bottom five in the NBA and
if their actual cave behind the arc last
night you know Dana Green was 7 of 9
from three-point range that's that's
amazing right there no wonder he scored
28 points right so 3-point shooting for
once was not their issue in a game it
really was defense they were good in
that in that category in that first
quarter but then Clippers had a 40 point
second quarter and really it was kind of
on from there the Clippers really
outpacing the Lakers many more
fast-break points the Lakers have seen a
step slow in many categories last night
Mike thanks for getting up early we
appreciate your time we'll check in with
you during this season thank you that's
Mike Bresnahan Laker analyst specs from
spectrum Sports Net also cover the
Lakers 12 years for the LA Times for
more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on be our live or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]